so you've been rumoured to a few
different things for the future in terms
of projects I know you're in the tail
end of this but do you know what you're
doing next to be honest I I don't and I
am there's a there are a few projects
that I am attached to there's this
undying love which is a graphic novel
that I've loved for a long time and
Tommy Wirkola has gotten through the
first draft and who is a really good
friend and I think a great writer and
perfect for it so we're working our way
through that material we have the
division which is a incredible property
two great actors and producers on it you
know Jake and Jessica we're waiting a
script from a really talented writer
Rafe who's a gonna deliver draft soon
and I think that that's also sort of you
know there's a lot of people involved in
that one it's creative creative
producers and actors so we'll have been
put on the descript and then they have
schedules and so we'll see where that's
how that's all going people don't
realize scheduling is everything it is
it is you know they you know they all
have great careers and you know
everyone's like you know wants to work
and so you're like give me four things
that actually come together when these
attachments happen it's it's usually a
miracle in a sense but uh and I'm sure
you're you're looking at like 2021
so you have three months in 2021 can you
line that up yeah it's sometimes it's
like that you know but I think there is
a motivation obviously from Netflix and
from you know Jake and Jessica and
myself to make that happen so we'll see
and look as the material starts to come
together is it you know all the move in
the movie we all want to make and we're
excited about and hopefully it is I mean
I love to pitch and we all love that
world